[Music]
new mutants are dangerous
you're not only anywhere this place
takes your greatest fear place your live
through it
Roberto
[Music]
Danny
brain we didn't get out of this together
this place is designed keep us his head
[Music]
[Music]
I was so high the New Mutants rated
pg-13 and on July 23rd don't miss the
New Mutants panel at comic-con at home
what's the last thing you remember
Danny he said we had to route the reason
you survived it's because you're a very
uncommon girl not anymore
do you know a mutants or would anyone
like you she had their first time brain
I was 13 I thought it was a dream I just
lost control
son I've started panicking people got
hurt
Roberto my girlfriend had partnered
Viviana
I killed 18 men one by one
[Music]
there's no hospital it's a cage
[Music]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
I saw something I don't think she wanted
me to see
I don't think we're here to cut better
this place takes your greatest fear it
may see related through it until it
kills you
he's there we can get out of this
together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]